hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast FDA and lab developed tests in
clinical labs
I'm Robert Castellanos of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by Lambert's the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning they have a few important
announcements before we began this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window have any
technical problems viewing or hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button in
lower left this is a educational webinar
and this offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would like
to introduce today's speaker dr. Singh
dr. Singh is director of the Mayo Clinic
in doctor and laboratory he has a focus
area of investigation that has broad a
kabila T to the field dr. singh's
studies the application of liquid
chromatography tandem mass spectometry
to clinical laboratory analysis many of
the methods that dr. Singh developed are
now considered reference methods they
have subsequently been utilized for
method standardization efforts as well
as to establish clinical disease
correlates which he has published with
his collaborators dr. Singh has worked
directly contributed to improving
methods for clinical diagnosis of
Cushing's disease fail promote Toma and
congenital adrenal hyperplasia he has
continued to work to discover
innovative ways to better understand the
use of liquid chromatography Canton mass
spectometry
in providing patients with faster and
more accurate diagnosis I'll now hand it
over to the doctor for his presentation
Thank You Bobby
I would like to paint lab groups for
organizing this wonderful events so the
topic has was announced she's going to
be FDA and mass spec tests for clinical
labs and I will also like to thank that
pier for sharing some knowledge in the
public domain
I'd like to start again with the
disclosure and disclaimer that this
presentation is only for educational
purposes and may not be presents the
view of the FDA and the Mayo Clinic I
had an opportunity to attend a public
workshop organized by the FDA on May 2nd
in 2016 and title of the workshop was
mass spectrometry in the clinic
regulatory considerations throwing
renovation of liquid chromatography mass
spectrometry based devices on May 2nd
the focus was the use of mass spec in
proteins and peptides but during some of
the sessions the knowledge was also
shared how the Nasdaq has impacted the
clinical testing in the clinical
laboratories it was very clear during
the workshop that mass spectrometry is
then known to the FDA and FDA believes
that the mass spec is underutilized for
proteins and peptides and in oddly
enhance the interactions between the FDA
and the clinical mass spectrum in the
community they would like to organize
more and more educational and
communication between the two and after
you believes communication and
collaboration with the political mass
spectrometric committees can identify
the opportunities for FDA to provide
help in developing the mass spectrometry
based devices to enhance their entry
into the clinic and thus improve the
here this particular slide further
emphasizes that FDA and their department
which is the Center for Devices of
radiological health all the office of in
breach or radiological help strongly
believe that they should stop and
communicate with the device
manufacturers sponsors of the various
manufacturers and the people who are
intelligent to develop novel
technologies the Center for medical and
Medicaid Services regulate all the
laboratory testing performed on humans
in the GS through the clinical lab
improvement amendment Korea which stands
for PETA lab Employment Act
approximately go once 254,000 labs now
and again the purpose is to ensure that
most of these labs report quality
testing and provides the best clinical
testing to the patient care so the
clinical lab Improvement Act was passed
by the Congress in 1988 and it's known
as clinical and improved Act of 1988 and
overall the purpose of this particular
bill was Congress would like to regulate
every test in every lab to of the land
including those in physician's office
FDA was also given responsibility to
monitor the risk associated with various
lab tests and the device is used to
perform the various testing FDA has
classified these devices into three
categories Class B is a category it
belongs to the device which can have a
higher risk or present
unreasonable risk of injury or illness
or can be life-threatening to the
patient a fear has deeper oversight over
this in comparison class 2 devices of
the moderate risk general controls are
not sufficient but can be mitigated
through special controls class 1 devices
could be waived by the FDA which have no
whisper patient care
after year during the workshop made it a
point that they are very straightforward
and they would like to help the vendors
to get their devices in the market to
help the patient either through the
pre-market approval process which is
full of Class C devices all through the
510 K approval process which can be
followed for the Class two devices when
is the 510 K required according to the
FDA any device which needs to be bring
into the market after he made a 28 1976
has to go through this process and this
particular 510 K requirements are listed
in the next few slides and in order to
make sure that of a mass spec is
delivering the quality results I would
like to review how mass spec has come
into the clinical labs so the clinical
labs have been using in the past some
kind of color metric reactions for
example we used to do 20 metric
reactions for steel whites and then we
went from steroid metabolites in urine
to do it by chromatography then we went
to using gas chromatography
but then revolution was there when radio
amino acids were discovered and that
helped us bringing the testing of the
pinnacle layer into the plasma versus
the testing we do anyway but very slowly
because realize that there are some
issues with the amino acids then it was
decided that isotope dilution GCMs can
overcome the problems we observed with
the amino acids but it was impractical
because of the cost in the team and
required to use isotope GCMs in various
panic opportunities in the clinical labs
this particles like further highlights
the dr. Rosen and yellow was given no
Nobel Prize for inventing the amino
acids which could detect were sensitive
enough to detect the analytes in serum
or plasma this was the era of when we
could go from urine
testing to the plasma testing plasma
Justin could be painful but it is
believed that all the analyte which are
in circulation are better representative
of the disease than the metabolites in
urine and this was a pretty big
revolution in the industry then radium
investors were converted to
chemiluminescence amino acids or enzyme
lacked amino acids or for a sense of
universes or chemiluminescence based
sandwich asses now in a clinical lab we
don't only have the amino acids but when
the ministers don't work in real life
you also depend upon the mass spect
assays or the chromatography assays
which are listed here and this is all
the math look like in 1980s we used to
do manual Eliza's in see them than we
used to count in a very manual laborious
ways in the scintillation counters and
the side the fact was we were using a
lot of radioactivity then our vendors
were able to convert those really amino
acids to competitive chemiluminescence
bases which were much easier to automate
and this is how the modern lab looks
like which is very much cleaner than the
previous slides you saw and there is a
very minimal touch to the patient sample
and the technologist would love to work
in these labs and our turnover has
decreased the clsi is another
organization which is clinical and the
watery stand institute also has started
providing guidance to the various
vendors and to the clinical labs who are
trying to develop either the new formats
of the old analyzer or trying to develop
new asses
see LSA is then recognized by the sierra
CDRH or the oír or branch of the fda and
they don't believe that they need to
reinvent guidelines the others they have
in those all the clinical guidelines
developed by clsi for example i'm
showing it here
EPO 588 b-17 a2 and some of the
guidelines are very clear from
the LSI that we should use a real tation
dueling of development and validation we
should use the samples from the intended
population and we should make sure that
we are designing the test we should
cover all the analytical measurement
page and we should also make sure that
the test can distinguish between the
clinical affected people and the normal
people this particular slide will
highlight that the in first in the mass
spec is increasing over the period of
time if you just notice on this a bottom
blue bar here part of the part here in
comparison to various of the
technologies the use of the LC tendinous
definitely is increasing in the newborn
screening but I would emphasize today
that its use is also increasing in other
clinical specialities also FDA
proactively has provided guidance to the
industry and here is an example where
they have a class to special control
guidance document for newborn screening
test system for amino acids pre
carnitine and acyl carnitine using
tandem mass spectrometry like I was
saying that the mass spec is not only
useful biochemical genetics or inborn or
level of metabolism for amino acid or
capitainesj rather it is also be used
for steroids and catecholamines and
other molecule genetics here is an
example here if the testing for a
patient which you see on the slide here
has Cushing's and this patient looks
like Cushing's but this patient
resembles very much with the people who
in the u.s. population who is obese and
has a hypertension but if we miss the
stage in who has a tumor either in the
brain or the adrenal gland then this
patient can die versus if we perform the
cortisol testing by mass spec well then
we can save the life of this patient and
this patient can return back what she
used to look like before she had
developed the disease
so let's talk a little about the issues
we have the Corso testing so there are
some issues with the iminium essay and
that is the reason the clinicians do
call the lab that when they don't
believe the result is correct they would
like the lab to repeat the testing with
HPLC UV methodology which also has some
issues then ultimately we have to do the
testing by using LCMS and this is the
list of various compounds which can
cross react with the antibodies used in
these amino acids and those particular
analytes are highlighted with the
circles here and you can notice here
that the premise alone has a cross
reactivity with the antibody which is
developer Coleco but it can also cross
react with the premise alone and it can
also cross react with a six six methyl
prednisone by 21% and some of the other
precursors of course also do cross react
so what this means is there anybody used
for the amino acid can have over
estimation of the CODIS or result which
can provide false positive results and
this is also clear from this comparison
that if you notice here the method
comparison by using tenant aspect and
using the minimus a is far from perfect
it only lacks it not only lacks the
slope that means mass spec only provides
month of the volume values but it also
lacks the correlation that there is no
good correlation between the two
methodologies and also the amount of
CODIS or present in the serum is one
third of the value approximately the
value which is obtained by the amino
acid
so that means anybody used in the essay
probably has a cross reactivity to the
coding of metabolites and it is well
known now that is significantly cross
reacts with the Corazon which is one of
the major metabolites
this is an example here if you take the
same sample from the patient which had a
cross reactivity with the code is drawn
or prednisolone
you run an HPLC you can separate those
two peaks but even in the HPLC method
there are some drug interferences where
you don't resolve these Peaks very much
and the technologists not only have to
work all day to process these samples
but then in the end they may not be
satisfied with the quality of the
results which are obtained by the HPLC
you'll be then in the end the labs have
to run the same sample by using lc/ms if
you compare the previous chromatogram
with this particular one you notice this
has much cleaner milligram and it has a
cortisol and Coons all peak separate and
we don't see any interference because of
the other drugs or the premise on crime
is known but what you notice here is
still this method runs for almost more
than twenty minutes
it requires hockey of extraction the
invention of liquid chromatography
attendant aspect we are able to do this
testing much faster this slide
highlights that clinicians are wondering
why even we are performing the journal
corazones is by using amino acids so
does at Mayo Clinic we have switched the
coating on acids to the liquid
chromatography tandem aspect where not
only we can separate collision from
cortisone but we can also maintain is
pre analytical process by using the
internal standard and as you all already
are noticing the turn a long time or the
run time of this particular essay is
also very short that in two minutes you
can get results compared to the 20
minutes is used in a single lc/ms so we
also have some problems with the
testosterone amino acids especially in
women as you notice here the structure
of testosterone and dihydrotestosterone
is very similar and if the antibody was
raised against testosterone or
dihydrotestosterone they can cross
reacting with each other
and here is the list provided by the
manufacturer or by the investigators
that the antibody against testosterone
does have a cross reactivity with methyl
testosterone after 12.2% and some other
drugs up to 6.7% the even do the cross
reactivity is in the range of 6 to come
person but the doses of these drugs or
the synthetic testosterone uses in much
higher concentration that it can result
in very high value for falsely high
value for testosterone in patient sample
this was the editorial published in
clinical chemistry which I'm going to
zoom in which kind of questions that out
of the various amino acids
none of the lessons were as good as the
gas chromatography in GCMs which is
considered the gold standard method but
the GCMs sense is impractical for most
of the endocrine labs because it is
laborious and most of the GCMs work now
can be performed on LC ms/ms and that is
what has happened in real life in
various clinical labs this is another
example here where the testosterone by
the amino acid specially room and woman
is also impacted by the levels of SPG as
that BG values though go high in
pregnancy or the woman with the
contraceptives and because the icdbg ha
is high the amount of testosterone
recovered in the total testosterone acid
by the amino acid is not very consistent
or precise and this is one manufacturer
on the left and on the right the
manufacturer may have lost bias but
still there is a lot of variability
where you cannot predict which patient
will have good recovery of testosterone
and there is a change in the acid PT
concentration there is a lot of
literature like this available where the
transform values have been questioned in
women and in children the similar issues
we have seen in for vitamin D vitamin D
is a
very hot topic you can collapse because
its association has been or is clinical
use has been found to be malabsorption
effect of the various medication its
ruling cardiovascular diseases cancers
and other diseases this particular has
the highlights that normal so soft like
in a DEA son but because of the concern
with this skin cancer most of the people
are using vitamin D supplements and
those supplements can be vitamin D or
each you both forms of vitamin D we go
through the liver and we'll get been
working to 25 hydroxy vitamin D then
which will get converted to 125 hydroxy
vitamin D which is a bioactive hormone
but this bioactive hormone changes with
the calcium intake is does not
considered as a good environment to
monitor the nutritional level of vitamin
D so the 25 hydroxy vitamin D is
considered to be the biomarker if you
are interested in determining the
nutrition level of vitamin D as the
vitamin D which is ingested quickly gets
converted to 25 hydroxy vitamin D so
various manufactures have very quickly
developed the 25 hydroxy vitamin D
assays and those esters have been
cleared by FDA through the 510 K process
but unfortunately when you compare those
essays with the gold standard HPLC and a
meth method it is seen that those s is
not only provide less precision less
accuracy but they are not also
clinically consistent and in this
particular it was highlighted that both
radium universes and chemiluminescence
amino acid seem to overestimate the
vitamin D deficiency in general
population what you will get
compared to by using HPLC method even by
UV method and by MS method so this could
be concerning because a lot of people
may be over taking work in Indy
so this particular example further
highlights a HPLC or LC ms/ms method is
the gold standard
then we should work together to help the
vendors who are making the amino acids
to help in standardizing and work under
the umbrella of FDA to provide better
quality of the testing for patient care
our endocrine colleagues also are very
conscious of the problems we have the
amino acids and they are reminding us
that the lab especially the clinical
labs should not only provide the
proficiency testing which is provided to
the care but their proficiency testing
should be run in a manner that is
accurate and precise and the procedure
only is good enough not good enough
according to the American and open
society and this is the cartoon which
highlight what accuracy means that you
at the target you know that Center is
centered and that is the accurate value
for testosterone vitamin D or other
compounds and then hopefully all the
clinical labs and all the vendors could
nail it down and get the accurate values
most of the vendors who provide
automation solutions do provide great
precision and that precision sometimes
is even difficult when we are doing
manual eliza's or manual LC ms/ms asses
so we need to take advantage of the
automation and the LC ms/ms so that we
can provide accuracy and precision so
when I look at my menu of the testing we
offer in a clinical lab menu gets
divided into two day classes one we call
a small molecular weight one we call it
large molecular weight and this example
will help you in illustrating that the
amino acids belong to the small
molecular weight may have some issues
but those issues are much less when it
comes to the high molecular weight
proteins and this particular example
highlights that because of the small
molecular weight of all these all just
for us true and by community you
use only one antibody and then you have
to use a label analyte which is called a
competition and then you provide a
competition configuration of the assay
then your signal to noise or the signal
will depend inversely proportional to
the concentration of the analyte and
when the signal is inversely
proportional to the concentration of the
analyte that means it has the inverse
line here but because of the limited
antibody and the limited tracer the
other disadvantage is that the signal is
almost platinum the low concentration or
the high concentration that means the
precision of the amino acid is also not
good
either at the low concentration or at
the high concentration and it also has a
very limited dynamic range in comparison
when it comes to the large molecule of a
proteins we can use two different
antibodies antibody one antibody will
capture the antigen or the analyte then
we can turn the magnet on of the solid
phase photon we can wash all the matrix
proteins like albumin and the
immunoglobulins and clean up all the
reaction cell then we bring in a second
antibody which has a label on it then
the second antibody will only bind to
the antigen which is a large molecule
the protein then we can provide a
chemical signal by adding hydroxide or
providing other chemistry's then that
means the signal will be directly
proportional to the concentration
so these sandwich acids are amazing when
they work on the amino acids automated
wave forms they provide great linearity
great accuracy and great precision and
this is what is exploited in the
clinical labs clinical labs of providing
millions of asses results to the
physicians throughout the US and to of
the world and we are really really in a
good position where all these labs are
doing a wonderful job and because also
being provided
choosing mixture of multiple
technologies for some of the analyzed
where the amino acids don't work we had
to use LC ms/ms and in the big reference
lab the number of mass techs are being
used and you they get situated right
next to each other in front of the other
mass spec you have to use liquid
chromatography and even before you do
liquid monography
you would also have to prepare the
sample to clean up as much as your essay
will required based on your sensitivity
and specificity requirements for the
clinical assay then you are developing
your own assets in the lab you do have
CLS a guideline which clearly says that
it is a responsibility of the vendor to
make sure the SA has a good precision
good interest a precision good interest
a precision it has a good method
comparison with the gold standard method
it is a linear it has a good reportable
range it has a good method comparison
and it has a good population studied the
Z population and the reference in
population so that it can separate the
two populations and the analytical
sensitivity and specificity the clinical
labs are supposed to confirm even when
they buy the tests from the vendors
which have been FDA cleared or the
proved true just to confirm that what is
on the label actually works in real life
and to some of the mass spec companies
are working very hard to bring a
solution which will take an advantage of
the automation to improve the precision
and to have some kind of mass spec
detector added to the box so that it can
provide the specific result so the
precision will come from the automation
and the specificity will come from the
mass spec and that will be the best of
the two worlds so if we buy mass spec
only ball which is sold as not and D
device according to FDA that will be
cost one and should be only for R&D
purposes but it needs
using a reagent form and manufacturer
who will also sell the instrument that
according to the FDA this becomes his
system and would have to go through the
FDA clearance process and according to
the FDA 510 K process depends upon class
1 or class 2 cost Mamula time in the
exempt class 2 is based upon its
equivalence on the predicate device and
FDA has a very clear definition of
predicate device and I only encourage
the listeners to go to the FDA side and
get those clarifications FDA will have a
very quick review of this and we'll get
back to you in 19 dataview process FDA
Julie was a burned host when we attended
this workshop and she has also along
with her colleagues have published a
very nice paper here in the clinical
chemistry which shares FP experience
with a clinical mass spectrometry and in
this paper they are highlighting that
how in recent years they have been able
to clear through 510 K process three
different devices
the first device was a TLC 10 domestic
asset for crackle image and the second
was a TLC 10 and a spec for newborn
screening and payload which one is a
very modern application of the mass spec
in the shape and form of a motif off or
the malabar identification and that was
another revolution in the microbiology
how quickly the microbiology or
microbiologists have adopted the mass
spec to improve the patient care and
this is an example here the various
vendors who got disapprove of what kind
of data they submitted to the FDA and
what was the reviewing process by the
FPS everything is presented in this
pinnacle chemistry paper and I would
like to encourage you to go to this
paper as well and
in the end FTA gives this letter and as
you can imagine this is a very big deal
or a Rendell or a lab and you get a
clearance from FDA and looks like FDA
has they work law in place to get this
clear instance for LC ms/ms devices as
well and this is another example here
where waters got clearance for their
immunosuppressants gate and some of
their data included comparison with the
predicate device one and platicas device
two and it is listed what are the
advantages of the mass spec assays or
its equal in c of that asses and I'd
also list what are the differences
between the two S's so everything is
very cross the range the vendor did a
good job
FDA reviewed it and in the end medical
community was able to make use of the
FDA clear test which is based upon the
mass spec which provides all the
advantages of the minimizes in terms of
the automation and precision and it also
provides the specificity as well and
this is the way people do the FDA
website you can look at the information
what was submitted then to the FDA if
you are new in this area of the business
everything is available in the public
domain the political workshop which FDA
had called was to prepare the preachers
users which are working in the areas of
metabolomics and proteomics and they had
a very good handle on the folks were
working in genomics especially in the
next-gen sequencing but the community
they brought together was people who are
developing cancer biomarkers or
developing new database microbiology or
our colleagues and an optic pathologies
who are using more and more mass spec
for example in amyloid typing and other
diseases and dr. dopler in metal wall or
metal core from Arizona State University
was kind enough to share with our
workshop attendees that there are very
few tests which are you
in LC ms/ms in the class of high
molecular weight proteins and peptides
and the reason that as I said before is
probably because we don't have as many
issues with the proteins and peptides
because we are using sandwich asses but
now as we are discovering knowledge I
owe markers or they may be interested in
rediscovering some of the ISO bonds or
the radius well-known proteins and we
can take an advantage of LC ms/ms in
those area as well but FDA wouldn't like
that worked with a vendor so that
because they some of the reagents and
trypsin being used is something novel
which we don t use in the LC ms/ms for
small molecular weight and that can
affect the quality of the testing and
FDA would proactively like to provide a
guidance to the vendors of the lab so
that the process gets done smoothly and
some of those reagents are listed here
mass spec HPLC and sample problems are
same for all the mass spec acids but the
trypsin and the antibodies will be
unique to be used for the proteins and
peptides and that's where FDA would like
to collectively understand and work with
the vendors to look at the limitations
of these reagents and pa was also very
clear in this particular workshop there
or local model which device there there
is no predicate you still can go to the
FDA and they will help you could decide
if the device is ready for clinical use
and is said and this particular beam or
device can take up 220 days a little bit
longer than what it takes for 510 K and
the class 3 devices are very serious for
everybody for general public or clinical
labs for the vendors and generally
requires more time but more
communication without the air the better
outcome and this process will take
longer because it will require multiple
levels of meetings with the advisory
panels of different layers of FDA
communication in their office after a
also presented a very good case that
either encourage the intellectuals and
other developers of the esses that how
they can start thinking about this
process when you're developing a new LC
ms/ms assay for a new cancer market
where there is no predicate device an
example here is that Acme diagnostic is
developing a normal peptide they sell
CMS quantitative in vitro diagnostic
device for the protection of spider
protein of course it is a joke and it is
an age to diagnosis of that syndrome
again another sense of humor there and
this company would like input from FDA
own validation intended using other
courses in a face-to-face meeting and
the one of the question is that sponsor
is asking is that we supposed to fall
and predicate a rebel diagnostic has a
spot for Eliza
does FDA I lived with this predicate and
FDA answer could be in such a situation
the choice of the predicate is up to the
sponsor whether you want to propose that
this is the predicate device and they
use a similar and the principles of the
similar however we know what according
to the FDA that the predicate you have
selected was cleared in 1992
since that time understanding of the
biology of the disease has progressed
and regulatory practice has evolved you
strongly suggest that you can stall
publicly available to see in some reason
the website for the most current
regulatory expectation
the second question by the sponsor is
that we propose to test to monitor
conditions
500 normal healthy controls in our
clinical study does FDA agree with this
proposal FDA answer in this case would
be no we do not agree
has proposed including normal healthy
subjects in yesterday however these
subjects are not part of the intended
clinical population and therefore
testing your device with these subjects
will not present an accurate reflection
of your device specificity you should
also test subjects with a condition with
the intended use of population to
determine sensitivity specificity
positive predictive value negative
predictive value of a device we note
that you are performing reference range
and they really appreciate that is also
essential and they do comment that
lender has taken a proactive approach to
determine that reference range as well
vendor is asking another question we
propose testing agreement with the
predicate using a two into two
concordance table because the predicate
is a qualitative device versus
quantitative does FDA agree with this
proposal and that p8 likely would say
yes we agree that in this case
containing the performance of your
device to that or predicate by
concordance would be appropriate so in
summary the FDA has opened a lot of
channels and doors for people who are
the clinical diagnostic business whether
we are vendors whether we are labs
helping the patient care and the
clinicians and there is a process called
queue submission where there is no
penalty in starting this negotiation
this will have no negative impact on
your final outcome of a proposal this is
a pair only starting your conversation
and then getting some guidance to the
best FDA can based upon their previous
but I don't see any negative in that I
think this will help in making the
product better and safe for the patient
care so my conclusion is that when I was
there I got really impressed and got
educated FDA believes that we should
talk to them and they don't have
intention of developing new diagnosis
most of us in the clinical lab business
I'm very well aware of the CLS
guidelines and you should take advantage
of those and
in designing of new masses and political
performance testing is critical for the
clearance of the approval of the LC
ms/ms devices thank you very much for
your attention back to you Bobby thank
you well thank you for your presentation
before we get started on the question
and answer session I would like to
remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green through
and a button at the lower left of the
presentation window we're gonna try to
answer as many questions mistimes allow
dr. our first question is what aren't
the limitations of the mass spec thanks
Bobby
great question so Nasdaq is relatively a
new technique for the clinical labs
compared to the amino acids which we
have been using in the clinical labs and
as I indicated that the pre analytical
process is little laborious for mass
spec testing in addition people apps
have been using ministers for decades so
we know the limitations advantages and
disadvantages but the master is
relatively new to us so we would have to
understand what are the disadvantages
and that will come the period of time
and experience the other is that we may
have to define new reference ranges
because we have old reference ranges
based upon human assets one concern also
comes in a specialty like mine when we
are testing in the graphic population
that you don't have enough sample to
work with an sample requirement for LC
ms/ms may be much more than the amino
acids thanks Bobby
our next question what is the role of
CIP and how does that differ from FDA
FDA is a public and common body and was
given it was possibility and does have a
legal power as well.she regulate the
labs and regulate the manufacturers in
reality so far most of the vendors
because they bring their devices to the
market have been working with the FDA
and only the labs were working with the
clinical trials were involved with the
FDA but the labs which are purely
performing the clinical lab testing were
only had a working relationship at
College of American Pathologists or care
so College of American Pathologists is a
nonprofit organization and is a group of
professionals where they have a great
mission to help them maintain the
quality of the testing in the clinical
lab and cap has a great history and it
does go and provides the inspection and
it is conserved as a peer-to-peer but I
would say it doesn't have that legal
what I know so far it is an autonomous
body in a nonprofit organization and
it's very unclear that how these two
bodies like FDA and capital work so that
the last and the one-ders mainly
complies thank you
and we do have time for one last
question does this have any impact on
human research so cool
know what my understanding is that FPA
would like to use more and more use of
mass spec to discover new biomarkers in
the area of the proteomics even in
genomics but since the expectations and
the role of the public involvement is
increasing FDA would like that all those
studies are done in humans and their
time in a very good clsi guidelines
manner so that if we discover some
biomarker which is going to go to the
clinical trial that it has been designed
and validated really according to the
best guideline so that you don't have to
withdraw the product from the market so
we all are very cautious about it so the
more we could do up current research
work under the best guidelines I think
we all will be then then in the end
thank you and to wrap up today doctor do
you have any final comments for your
presentation before we let you go oh I
think I enjoyed this presentation and I
would encourage that log is happening in
the area of not Diagnostics because we
are discovering something new biomarkers
or we are using some testing which has
not been a fear cleared and as long as
we stay in communication and we use the
best technology for patient care and I
think it's a time and period where the
communication has a lot of value and we
can learn from each other and we can
help each other out and in the end we
all will feel proud that we have helped
the patient and we all feel good about
it thank you
like to thank dr. Singh again for his
outstanding presentation I'd also like
to thank recruits for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through February of 2017
you will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
for that announcement to your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye